[Musique]
au son des tambours des chants et des
prières les communautés culturelles de
la réunion se recueillent face à la mer
près du Lazar en hommage aux
travailleurs
engagés il qui est réalisé par le
département par les associations et je
crois qu'on n'est pas bien évidemment
arrivé au bout du chemin mais vous
pouvez compter sur le soutien du
Département pour que ensemble on
continue à construire une belle société
apaisée du bien vivre ensemble du bien
travailler ensemble o chaque communauté
puisse participer à l'élan collectif à
l'élan commun c'est le 20e anniversaire
de cette cérémonie venu d'Inde de Chine
d'Afrique ou de Madagascar les engagés
ont façonné l'identité culturelle
réunonnaise aujourd'hui leurs
descendants perpéttu ce travail de
mémoire et de tradition donc pour nous
moment très fort moment de recueillement
moment on va dire de de foi de
recueillement commun en tout cas je
pense que c'est ce qui fait notre force
à la Réunion donc c'est important
aujourd'hui de venir ici et de rendre
hommage et pourant et je dirais même que
c'est TR peu par rapport ce que engag
ont faire pour nous et c'est grâce à
aujourd'hui que nous sommes
là